the alphago has been using deep learning
to make this happen than is up yes yes
that's I mean the company that did that
well now is Google right but is the deep
mind company that was a start-up in
London and Google acquired them at some
point before actually anyone knew what
they were doing right so they were
smelling that with something nice right
and they're the best things that they're
doing deep learning with reinforcement
learning
right so reinforcement learning is the
type of way you try to teach and deep
learning is attracted type of algorithm
that you that you use to try to learn
that right so the reinforcement learning
is exactly this thing of I'm not going
to tell you exactly what they are what
the output is I'm just going to tell you
what is the task and I'm going to tell
you whether you're doing the task well
or bad and it's going to be your your
job as an algorithm to find the best way
of doing these tasks
first idea that we have to understand is
with what we're trying to do with it
right which is basically machine
learning is a is trying to automate
automatically do some tasks that what we
can do it by counting usually right we
can do basically statistics but if we
have a really lot of numbers we can end
up doing some heuristics what we can
come up with right and we might want to
use computers to actually learn from
these statistics in an optimal manner
say the best way of finding these
information out of this data that you
have is following these rules right so
the computer does this for you this is
this is the basic concept of machine
learning right one typical example is if
you want to invest in a either an
exchange market on the stock market
something like that and then I guess the
people that invest they have 13 rules
right if you have last five weeks going
on in the value then overall respect
that this week will go down because it's
been like reaching a maximum or this
kind of idea right that you complete the
medium of the last ten values and this
gives you an idea of the real value and
if it's above that it will go down and
and so forth right but this is just
basically heuristics that we think might
work right and we can even through
experience think that some are better
than others and so forth right but we'll
have like 50 values on the different
stocks in the market and we have you
know like the currency exchange and we
have many other factors right how - how
many rules can we find there how many
heuristics right this is just almost
infinite number so what you would like
is ideally a way of choosing the best
and the computer can has a capacity of
checking them all right you can do that
pen and paper you spend like five
lifetimes doing it and maybe you know by
the time you finish this no stock market
but the computer does it everything for
you very quickly right so the only thing
is it will not do something better than
you can do giving enough time but just
do it so much quicker that you will
never get the
right so now we're beginning to see
cases in which machine learning is
actually doing something better than
humans especially with very specific
tasks and maybe better than humans that
are not experts on that task right but
historically machine learning was always
worse than an expert human doing
something right
so one of the cases is this like now
famously alphago right so they say this
is one of the few cases in which machine
learning has managed to beat to beat the
an expert I mean like the world expert
on the on one specific problem right and
this mean this is all this talking about
why this is different from chess right
the main difference is that for chess
you have a limited number of options
right and once you move one piece right
then you have I don't know how many
options right but again a limited number
so you can organize that in a tree and
more or less check exhaustively you tell
the program and this is what you want to
do check all the options and just you
know do what is best according to what I
told you that is good right so this is
just sheer computational power in order
to check the options right this this
tells you our computers are really
powerful right but it doesn't say
anything about the algorithm itself
right with go it's totally different
because there are so many options that
you cannot really check them right a lot
of people are repeating this fact that
there's more go positions and particles
in the universe the people in deep mind
which is the people that did these have
said that they really don't know what
kind of tactic the computer is following
right they didn't really hard code any
tactic so what they did is they created
this machine learning algorithm right
that that would play go right and would
play it terribly right it's just you
know some random rules they didn't
really have a clue how to implement that
so they started at some random
algorithm that would play go terribly
right and the point is that they pitted
this this this machine this algorithm
against some other algorithm that would
have different parameters right would
play go differently right but you still
wouldn't hard-code anything is would you
some parameters that would define how
you would play but you you really don't
know what the meaning of this parameters
are right and they would play against
each other and at some point after 100
matches one would win right and you say
okay this one is better and then you
keep these parameters you change them
somehow right and you keep on doing that
for very very long time it's a bit like
evolution there is a part of computer
science that is called the
evolutionary computing right so I don't
want to this is this is a slightly
different thing right but the concept is
you have a parameter space right and
this will tell you all the possible ways
to play go according to you know your 13
machine learning algorithm right it will
it will have certain possibilities that
are specific to that algorithm but you
have a lot of parameters in its
parameter can take a real value so you
have infinite possibilities and the
question is how to find the best
parameters to play go most machine
learning algorithms they have you search
for the optimal parameters in some other
way this this was a specific of a type
of problems that are called
reinforcement learning where you you
basically tell them what you want to do
but you you are not sure which is the
correct way of doing it right and that's
why deep mind says we don't really know
because they didn't gives the examples
for the machine to imitate they said
okay tried to learn by yourself
right this is what you want to do what
we want you to do just learn how to do
it every time that the machine learning
decides a move right so this is this is
what the algorithm is learning we have
this configuration what is my next move
right you are not specifying the best
move is this because no one knows right
I mean the idea is that they beat the
world champion so you know maybe now the
algorithm was able to figure out which
next move was better and better than
than the world champion right so there's
no golden standard to imitate there
right
the difference in essence I suppose I
don't really understand the game go so
that doesn't help much but suppose the
biggest thing here is and feel free to
kind of correct me but in chess you can
brute-force it yeah
yeah and in go you can't you thought
beefer that is this very fair yeah I
mean you still have to do it smartly to
brute-force it for chess because you
have to find a way to tell the computer
whether a movie is a smart move or not
down the line right but you still will
check all the consequences of your move
right but this is kind of a standard you
put a bit of domain knowledge and you
put brute force right
the goal is this is the totally
different game this is really fair
assessment of it
so basically there were two sets of
algorithms working against each other
and every time one did a bit better than
the other they thought yeah something
about that is better yes so that this
there were two different set of
parameters right of the same algorithm
right so the decisions that would take
would be different the algorithm was the
same with a needle network and basically
what you tell is the input is what is
the configuration right and then you
have a certain structure that will you
know like decide on the move right but
this is this structure is you need some
parameters that this is what in the end
the size right what so to see the
difference for example you can you can
see that you have a function that will
take the input and decide on the on the
output right this function you can
decide that this is a linear function
right oh so is just a line or or a plane
right is it display the traditional
like a regressing a line right and this
is when you modify the parameters of the
line this is this model is more or less
the same you change the slope of the
line you change the height of the line
right and this gives you different lines
right so this is exactly the same but
instead of having a line it was like
much more complex a function so that
will be until you dimensions but there
are just so many more dimensions yeah it
was not only about the dimensions it's
also about the way that the parameters
are structured right and this is why we
use the word deep on it right so a line
is what what we call a shallow a
structure of the other variables because
you just have some inputs and you
multiply by some values and you get the
app right so the inner indifference with
deep learning or well a deep deep
algorithms in general is that you have
certain input then you get some
intermediate variables by doing the same
is like if you fit a line and then you
fit another line and another line and
another line and then when you input
some values this will give you 13 values
right so you have like predictions right
these predictions are not the ultimate
thing that you need their intermediate
values that I do at the same time are
input to another layer of prediction
right and you go doing like that right
so the input to one layer is the output
of the previous layer right and this
hierarchical structure is a much more
powerful in the sense of what kind of
functions
what kind of the flexibility of the
function right you can model much more
complex things with many less variables
right and this is a decent magnificent
trade-off that gives it a lot of power
can go back and find historical examples
endless historical examples of people
claiming that something fantastic is
right around the corner we should get a
show okay
and we did okay so that's a good start
right we know our program works